so Paul and Lily you guys have worked
together already for those of you who
didn't see the 2013 film admission with
Tina Fey and Paul Rudd and you were
Tina's mom how did this all percolate in
your mind from that experience that you
would write this film for her I I would
not have written it without that first
up I find when I have a film come out
I'm kind of terrified and I usually I
try to be on the set of another movie to
alleviate the the anxiety and in this
case I was not a set another movie so I
decided to write something new and I had
Lily's voice in my head and also I
really felt having spent a little bit of
time Lily on that film that I wanted
something where she was going to be in
every scene and and look you know there
oddly in that movie Lily had to she had
to make sausage out of raw meat in one
scene and then she had to fix a bicycle
another scene and i'll always remember
going on set and seeing you literally
learning how to fix a bicycle with a
chain off and putting it on and then we
did the scene and it really struck me
that in the middle of this comedic
banter with tina she was literally
fixing the bike every time and if it if
she mixed up fixing the bike she would
stop her she would say i would they go
back regardless of whether the shot was
above what you were doing with your
hands but actually literally that that
that really told me something which
which was a type [ __ ] that I didn't know
when the camera was uh yeah and so so
when I sat down to write at Lily's
voices in my head
and it informed everything that the
character was doing so she really helped
me write it unfortunately I had not told
her I was writing something for her yet
so I sprung it on her at a lunch soon
after what was your reaction to that
well I was totally delighted I mean to
have a to have a movie you know with you
written with you in mind is very special
when you're sort of not a movie star in
that sense so I was I and it was a very
good movie and it was it was just sort
of fit like a glove so I was happy so
when the blood left your face it was a
pleasure as opposed to it's so fun to
watch all these other characters float
in and out of l's day and I was thinking
what it must be like as actors it must
be like being on deck knowing that
you're gonna face a great pitcher on a
baseball field what was it like for you
to kind of getting ready for those
moments that you were going to have with
Lily I was so nervous because because
it's lily and we'd never met I think the
first time we met we did a rehearsal in
the space which which didn't call me
down at all actually um for our first
day of shooting cuz I was like okay it's
fine we're gonna have rehearsal I'll
know what we're doing i'll meet her for
the first time but then i was just still
so nervous on the first day but it was
really incredible and um and and it was
nice to know that i liked being in a
movie that took place in one day I
thought yeah like these little like
stops along her way and i felt i was
excited to see like what the progression
of her stops you know what about you Sam
it's always daunting when you have an
opportunity to meet with someone and
work with him on you've been a huge fan
of for a long time in this case not only
Paul but lily and to work opposite
Lillian to play a love interest to Lily
was like wow you know
listen it was so great they're people
that are on the movie are so good I mean
that's just a tribute to paul don't you
think Sam doing did it was the material
the material just spoke to I think
across the board had spoke to all of us
and that in facts why we're there in
terms of my nerves yeah I was nervous I
was scared to death but it made me work
really hard on it before I got there and
I was ready to rock when I got there you
did I mean this is one of the most I
think intimate films I've seen in a long
time clearly it wasn't it was a intimate
production as well in 19 days that you
shot it yeah it was 19 days and credit
to the cinematographer Toby datum he
shot it or he lit it in such a fashion
that I never felt rushed with with the
actors it didn't there was never a
moment I said oh I have to move on from
something also we had a little bit of
time for rehearsal and and lily and I
had months really to sit down with the
script and every time I read a new draft
we would go over it and make sure that
stuff was making sense to us and yeah
the budget was just slightly under six
hundred thousand dollars which in this
case was really fine it was about two
people with no money so Sam in your
sequence with Lily the vulnerability
required from the two of you as actors I
guess must have been alternately
thrilling and frightening it was and I
think Paul and I were talking upstairs
about this this kind of small production
this little you know I mean it's it's
the ultimate in terms of creativity of
thinking but the thing the overriding
thing is just so damn much fun it's fun
it's it's unencumbered by all the
[ __ ] that comes with making big
movies and there's a lot of it
and it all allowed us to do it we did
certainly allowed me to do it did in
this guy just you know I mean every time
Paul came to me and it was so spare
whatever he would offer up but it just
it just goosed me all the more I'm gonna
think I was poking you're stabbing you
Oh somebody was poking me with something
given that it was such a scrappy
production when there's a scene like
Lily you and Judy arguing at each other
you know in the middle of the street did
you have rubber necker's whether people
kind of poking out their window saying
what is going on there's a couple big
pit bulls that walked by and I'm not
even joking there was no i don't i don't
remember anything i felt like i was
arguing with my ex-girlfriend yeah well
the funny thing is we were actually
right next to an acting school yeah and
and so so yeah literally walking in and
out where people who are aiming at the
end of it I don't know that they taking
notes I think they just thought is
another school production or something
with our footprint and Lily I've seen
you described this movie as humanists as
opposed to the word feminist why is that
distinction important to you well I
would say it was humanists because it it
tries to it it's um I think the the
highest it could be as humanists in
terms of just human behavior human
reactions trying to gather all the pull
all the points of view into one vehicle
and and not judging or so I think that I
I don't think it's him it's not that a
feminist film like this would have been
fine too as long as it really was
humanist but I think feminism is
humanism Sam I want to talk about this
incredible year that you had I'm a huge
fan of i'll see you in my dreams the
film with blythe danner i don't know if
you all have seen it maybe they showed
it here such a great performance than
that and now this are you excited about
these opportunities you're getting in
these great films this year
I'm dumbfounded by them but certainly
excited I mean we all after almost 50
years to still be at it is a wonderful
thing but to have the best of it coming
or certainly some of the best I think
probably the best it kinda at the end of
the road rather than the beginning I
sure do appreciate it and I'm really
enjoying it well I congratulate you all
Lily Paul Sam Judy thank you so much for
being having us thanks so much me wrong
with us